did anybody listening the opportunities
for your parents at your age is
completely different like they may not
have had a choice or they would have had
to be completely crazy and off the deep
end to go off and Chase down their
dreams like it was so much harder but
now there's a lot more that's possible
if I wanted to connect with Glenn on the
other side of the world I'm here in
Canada like it would have almost never
happened we'd be paying insane long
distance phone calls or flying and
taking forever like it just we wouldn't
have connected and now we're doing this
and it's only getting easier and so the
ability to have success both in terms of
financial success but also fulfillment
success and happiness in a 2022-2023
2024 environment it's just so much
easier than it used to be and you're
actually rewarded for it now compared to
before